Collapse? There is no collapse!
We can make this work!
Just shoot us an opening, Ben.
-I...I...can't.
-I figured this moment would come.
-You figured this moment would come?!
You brought me here!
-I did what I was supposed to do.
-Kyrie, no!
Don’t leave me with these scrubs!
-Luckily, you were able to join this superteam, right?
-So is this like, ya'll's downtown or...?
-No, this is the Nash Path.
The quickest way to the tournament.
And where I can finally beat...him.
-That’s them, all right.
Luka’s carrying all the weight.
Attack!
-Look out!
-Oh, phew. It's just the Suns.
Thought it was refs.
Thank you.
-Wait...
It’s Kyrie.
And he’s actually planning on participating!
♪♪♪ Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Riaru-sa misetayo ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Born to be a legend ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Hikari o mezashite ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
-Kevin, you must relax.
-Relax?! There is no relax, champ.
I’m on 10!
-OK, what's the game plan?
-Look, I'm not the savior here.
I’m watching just like everyone else.
-Good thing it's just my sons.
Hello, Book!
It’s Daddy Luka!
-Totally legitimate Warriors rings: GO!
[Rings flash]
[Water crashes]
[Energy balls blast]
-Hey! Y'all are shooting more than me.
-[sigh] Deandre...
-Not fair! I don’t wanna be here! Hmph!
-Looks like the odds are...even.
-Ugh! You and your numbers!
-Too hot...
[Energy ball whirrs]
TO HANDLES!
[Energy ball explodes]
-Ooh!
-Illegal powerball.
He took three steps!
Doesn’t count!
[Voice echoes]
[Record rewinding]
-Man...snitch.
-Well, I’ve done my role.
[Guitar sting]
-Come on, Russ. I mean, Steph. I mean, Kyrie. I mean, Book.
-You handle Kevin.
I’ve got this!
[Screaming]
-Isolation Chamber!
[Punching noises]
-You started it!
-No! You started it!
-Ow, my groin!
-I can’t believe what you said.
-You’ll have to be more specific.
-You said you “did what you were supposed to do.”
Did that include betraying your best friend?
You don’t have to answer.
Your silence speaks volumes.
Easy Money Mid-Range!
[Energy barrage blasting]
-Invisible Defender!
[Both yelling]
[Somber violin]
-Kyrie, no!
Don’t leave me with these scrubs!
-[Yelling] Huh?
-Don’t you see?
I saved you.
I saved you because...
I may wanna join the Suns next year.
-No, Kyrie.
Not again.
I mean, well...maybe?
If you—but, no.
-Come on.
For some reason the Mavs have been terrible since I got here.
-I mean, yeah, but...
-What? Um...
-[Laughing]
While they focus on their little rivalry,
the No. 1 seed can go straight to Playoff Mountain.
-You know, Book...
since you have the 4th seed,
and the Mavs are out...
I think...
You might be the better player.
-Really?
-NO!
[Laughing]
Feels good to laugh.